stellt euch vor ihr wolltet vor 200
jahren einen schuh kaufen damals werte
zu einem schuster gegangen der eure füße
erst vermessen musste und danach in
mühevoller handarbeit einen passenden
schuh für euch hergestellt hat dann kam
die industrielle revolution und schuhe
wurden die massenware die wir heute
kennen umso mehr wert sind heute aber
seltene schuhe die oft für fünfstellige
beträge gehandelt werden und mit der
zeit sogar im preis steigen wie zb der
nike merkt er auf einer bekannten
handelsplattform zuletzt für 42.000 euro
seinen besitzer gewechselt hat
vielleicht kein wunder denn während
gängige sneaker millionenfach produziert
werden existieren davon weniger als 1600
stück aber wie geil wäre denn ein
sneaker den es nur einmal ein komplett
selbst designte und maßgeschneiderte
schuh der so crazy aussehen kann wie ich
will wie wir das machen fragt
tatsächlich mit dem 3d drucker ging
erstmal nur eine schnapsidee aber schon
länger wird es 3d druck bei großen
herstellern verwendet um prototypen
anzufertigen und immer mehr große marken
und startups wollen in zukunft mit 3d
druck auf persönlich angepasste schuhe
setzen und stellen schon jetzt
bestandteile oder sogar komplette
schulter mit her schon 2015 hat der ceo
von nyc angedeutet dass ihre schuhe bald
als datei zum selberdrucken verkaufen
könnten pro jahr davor das ist jetzt
sechs jahre her also wenn es mal langsam
zeit abzuschalten gemacht war das
mittlerweile ist ein gute 3d drucker
sind mittlerweile ja billiger als handys
auch wenn das 3d druckmaterial relativ
teuer ist auch nicht da auf jeden fall
eine kostenrechnung machen wird aber
besonders spannend wird ob das nickenig
design und herstellen werde auch das
aussehen wie heute ist nämlich montag
und ich will versuchen bis ende der
woche pünktlich zum bäcker in die kölner
innenstadt zu gehen und vor allem der
bekanntesten sneaker leben die leute
fragen was sie von meinem schuh halten
dafür habe ich ein fünf tage zeit also
netzkauf
auch komplett selbst entworfen habe ich
meine allererste eigenen klamotten also
dennoch stehen ihr euch jetzt gern mal
über den link in der mail die
beschreibung anschauen könnt nach den
ganzen jahren wird das auch wirklich
jetzt mal ne zeit aber ich wollte nicht
einfach nur irgendetwas rausbringen und
irgendwas raus zu bringen sondern ich
habe auf die idee gewartet und die hatte
ich jetzt mir kamen die idee so viele
alte zeiten im leonardo da vinci style
zusammen zu sammeln dass die kreativität
und den erfindergeist repräsentiert der
in meinen videos aber natürlich auch in
jedem von uns steckt und dann kamen sie
die idee wie wäre es denn wenn das
einfach meine eigenen zeichnungen werden
also die zeichnungen die bei meinen
verrückten experimenten hier drauf
entstehen es gibt jetzt also das
inventar shirt in weiß aber auch quasi
im dark mode in dunkelgrau und natürlich
passend für den winter den warmen in
wenzhou die in schwarzen steht jetzt
nirgends ein haft humorlose was drauf
ich wollte einfach ein geiles sein für
jedes alter und wie es gestellt wie als
community erkennen an den ganzen skizzen
was die kollektion bedeutet und alle
anderen denken sich einfach nur frisches
design der link zum treffpunkt job ist
in der video beschreibung eure
bestellung kommt natürlich vor
weihnachten an und bezahlen könnt ihr
also den kanal supporten oder etwas
gönnen wollt wie so ziemlich alles was
ihr habt sogar mit google oder apple
direkt am handy dank fürs zuhören ich
bin richtig froh dass es jetzt endlich
alles geklappt hat und damit geht's
weiter mit dem eigenen sneaker da ich
aber nicht so mega im sneaker game drin
bin und nicht weiß was einen krassen
sneaker ausmacht wo ich mal jemanden an
der etwas mehr ahnung davon hat worauf
es ankommt
was ist wichtig was nervt bei einem
sneaker was ist geil was sorgt dafür
dass du bock drauf hast müssen
grundsätzlich immer zum
[Musik]
eigentlich auch eine geschichte die
geschichte dahinter ist dass häufig die
begeisterung am menschen zusammen ok
dann danke dir und einen guten flug
ich glaube mal rein aber cool
so er fliegt einfach gerade nach new
york der flug geht in zwei minuten hatte
mir gerade geschrieben romanes mega
spontan aber bisher gelandet ist konnten
wir natürlich nicht warten wir müssen
jetzt direkt loslegen damit das eine
woche gehabt bevor ich meinen flieger
aber am pc entwerfen kann muss sich erst
mal meinen fuß in den pc reinbringen
dafür nutze ich so genannte
photogrammetrie das ist ein verfahren
bei dem nur auf der basis von bildern
eines gegenstands oder in diesem fall
eines fußes ein 3d modell erstellt wird
also auch wenn das jetzt aussieht wie
eine woche only fans selbst experimente
brauche ich die bilder aus verschiedenen
winkeln meiner füße damit die app daraus
ein 3d modell errechnen kann die vielen
schwarzen punkte helfen ihr dabei seid
hier ist der fuß richtig wehren im
amazon fußball ja ja und dann hans der
schuhgröße kann ich jetzt von unten nach
oben mit der schuhsohle anfang oder
weniger kann ich jetzt echt eins zu eins
an meinen fuß nach fahren
dann für ein bisschen anpassen war
normal span mails nicht wirklich eine
genaue fußform rausschaut weiß ich nicht
genau weiß wie viel platz man jetzt
genau zwischen fuß und diesen
außenwänden lassen soll damit er nicht
zu eng wird aber ich will sagen wir für
einsame raus
ich hab mir mal ein merger schon mit dem
ipad meine signatur digitalisiert weil
ich das für die t shirts und finden und
die kennt in den kragen eindruck klasse
weil ich hasse diese zeit lang war immer
die man noch mal an und schneide dir
sowieso abgrund reingeguckt na ja auf
jeden fall nichts neues wenn genau diese
signatur dieses unterschrift ding auch
in dem profil der schuhsohle drin und
dafür kann ich einfach direktor deshalb
verwenden die ich hier schon
[Musik]
so fertig ist das profil das wir uns
hoffentlich spieler richtig gut halt
geben und das kommt jetzt direkt in 3d
drucker und zwar mit diesem schwarzen
und extrem gummiartigen filament
[Musik]
leute hieß felix der kater von thomas
leider ist der ton hier ausgefallen und
thomas ist schon unterwegs weshalb war
kein ball mehr machen kann deshalb kurze
zusammenfassung was hier passiert ist
thomas hat sich auf jeden fall riesig
darüber gefreut dass die sohlen so schön
flexibel sind doch wie in den meisten
schulen fehlt halt immer noch material
was die schritte ein bisschen ab dämpft
weshalb wir hier so eine doppelhelix
förmige federung gebaut hat und einmal
eine lamelle formuliert hat und das
ganze auch gedruckt hat
[Musik]
ich bin super gespannt weil es mit dem
gummi werkstofflich nicht geil jetzt
das ist gehen auch super c ab
[Musik]
okay der moment der wahrheit taugt das
ganze was als mit anderen wird es dann
ja das ist ja super schlimm berichtet
hat es tatsächlich ganz gut geklappt es
ist ein bisschen silberfäden drin aber
es
stimmt frage ist welches dämpft jetzt
besser
es ist beides super spannende sowohl die
lamellen hier sind super spannend als
auch die helix das
letztendlich entscheide ich mich für
eine stark abgewandelte variante der
lamellen version mit deutlich dickeren
streben da das tastic zu flexibel war
und ich das design so viel cooler finde
diese form ist sehr futuristisch und war
mega schwer zu modellieren weswegen ich
alleine dafür über drei stunden
gebraucht habe mit dem ergebnis bin ich
aber mehr als zufrieden und das wird nun
gedruckt 3d druck ist schon etwas sehr
faszinierendes aber es wird spannend zu
sehen ob die struktur die hier gerade
entsteht überhaupt mein körpergewicht
aushält sonst könnte das ganze recht
schmerzhaft werden so das ganze hat
jetzt über nacht zwölf stunden schon
gedruckt geht aber noch fünf weitere
stunden brauchen und dann müssen
natürlich auch noch die sohle für den
anderen schulen ja so richtig viel zeit
und in der zwischenzeit mache ich mich
direkt an den schuh halt das was nicht
so leer und nicht profil ist und ich
will dich kein hierbei wird das so zu
design und so zu gestalten und material
zu wählen wenn es dann auch aus einem 3d
drucker heraus direkten funktionierten
schule gibt
[Musik]
morgen muss alles fertig sein und dafür
muss ich jetzt 33 den drucker
gleichzeitig befeuern damit das
überhaupt zeitlich möglich ist und das
ist es auch noch wenn jetzt alles klappt
so erstmal 3d druck filaments raus
machen und das andere rein ich hatte für
so ein paar rollen vorbereitet wir
brauchen wir die weiße
ich habe natürlich wieder gerade alles
gar nichts was ich muss also noch mal
neu einstellen wieso können sich aber
funktionierte zum nächsten übrigens
vielen dank an die jungs von credit
points die mir hier dieses krasse teil
zur verfügung gestellt haben sie jetzt
mal antesten wäre ein ausführlicher
bericht wird auch folgen für den drucker
drucken brauche ich die rolle dass ein
bisschen vetter die 3d drucke dauern
teilweise an die 20 stunden manchmal
brechen sie ab manchmal muss ich etwas
neu erstellen manchmal funktioniert
etwas nicht direkt auf anhieb es könnte
wie so oft alles so einfach sein ist es
aber nicht
so wird das sei übrigens abgemacht und
geerntet ist jetzt noch super früh ich
hatte meinen schlaf rhythmus ein
bisschen um die 3d drucke drumherum
angepasst und das sollten daher
abgebrochen ohne viele meldungen ich
habe immer mit markus gesprochen und er
meinte ich kann sein 3d drucker mal die
hosen hat dass ich noch mal ein extra
und kannst dass du vielleicht doch noch
heute schaffen und dann am black friday
quasi mein match in der innenstadt mal
präsentieren die leute fragen was sie zu
denken minimal kleinere 30 okay das
nicht nur minimal kleiner der schuh
passt einfach gar nicht rein also
eigentlich passt oft ran wenn man es
dreht und manchmal das so klöss kommt
ein kleines stück noch ist das knapp
okay let's go
also ich bin jetzt hier und haben
einfach eine harfe aufgebaut und wissen
sie mixt fahren das ist ja echt krass er
kann ich mal probieren da sehr richtig
geil ich spreche da gar nicht irgendwas
okay
also das ist
froh ich bin so neidisch auf dem platz
das wild ich weiß dass jetzt ein kommt
der schuh die obere hälfte so
lange auf jeden fall
und das wollte ich auch sagen so mit
marius hätte haben wir es geschafft wir
sind zeitlich leider trotzdem haben wohl
stücken verzog aber ich will den schul
jetzt fertig bauen ich habe alle teile
hier die
sohle
die zeit vergeht und das letzte fünkchen
hoffnung die schuhe in der shoppingmeile
am black friday vorzuführen schwindet
was für eine sauerei das zeug ist
überall
weiter geht das ist die sohle
mittlerweile kann man auch durch sehen
da kommen jetzt das profil rhein
wird dann mit kleber logischerweise
washington dass der welt konnte erst gar
nicht gehört so das scheint schon mal
gut zu sein dann kommen jetzt quasi das
teil als nächstes drauf und zwar so und
dann hinten so oh mein gott ich bin
gespannt wie das ding in sich tragen
wird also und 3d drucker ja nicht
einfach so in die luft gucken kann muss
oft sohlen unterstützungs material
darunter gebaut werden und das in dem
fall ist ultra krasser saison gitter aus
diesem gummi und ist letztendlich so ein
schaumstoff man kann es aber immer
wieder verformen und springt direkt
gesehen diese form zurück damit kommt
man zum vorletzten schritt petitionen zu
mässig muss ich hier jetzt im kleber
drauflegen jetzt noch ein bisschen
tricky das genau zu treffen so aber kein
fertiger schuhe ohne natürlich
schnürsenkel den rest der welt aus und
wäre das ja fernseh schule sein sollen
haben sich nur denken
also rein da ja mein gott er ist einfach
unfassbar leicht das ist echt krass und
das passt einfach es ist richtig krass
ganz optimal passt es ist mein es macht
auch voll sind das passt ja ich habe sie
genau nach meinem fuß modelliert aber
das ist es nächstes trotz wenig das
design sehr skurrile soll auch
futuristisch sein das fazit ist
wahrscheinlich dass man seine schuhe
noch nicht in 3d drucker machen kann
also tatsächlich fand ultra hässlich
aber jetzt durch den am wenigsten ganz
cool hat ein bisschen was man
schlittschuh würde ich sagen okay geht
ist es
hat ein bisschen was von steps muss man
sagen ja ich würde sagen dass und wie
sieht eigentlich tue
[Musik]
ich jetzt fragt wieso geht der vogel
nicht einfach am tag danach in die
emsstadt und fragte leute dann ist der
grund dass es gerade samstag 7 uhr
morgen ist und meine mama heute
geburtstag hat und dafür fahren wir
jetzt eine stunde los nach bayern und
sind sechs stunden auf der autobahn wenn
ihr wollt dass ich das mal ein zwei
kammer nachholen schreibe es in die
kommentare und wenn jetzt bock auf den
allerersten tom reach habt dann checkt
in der beschreibung haus gibt einen t
shirts sind übrigens aus 100 prozent bio
baumwolle aber jetzt gerne kanal wieder
gefallen hat und dann sieht man zunächst
angedacht macht's gut
[Musik]